Now before we explore touch support in detail, it's
imprtant to dunderstand that you may not even need to
do anything in order to support touch. Touch evenets emulate
mosue clicks already, and the web broswer builds in some
estures like scrolling and zooming. So, you only need to
implement somehtin here in cases where the gesture support Or
mouse emulation does not give an optimal user experience. In
fact, for most of our conference app we don't use
touch or pointer events at all. The built
in mouse emulation works great for clicking on
items and it's only buried inside the session
schedule and the map that touch is handled directly.